-Thank you, I appreciate that.
This is exciting.
You guys are nice.
I did a show recently, there was
a guy in the front row --
I thought he looked like me.
I was like, "Hey, man.
you look like me."
And then he went, "Oof."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Well, I didn't mean
to hurt our feelings."
[ Laughter ]
It was a bummer, but I
did realize that's probably
the best way to get a sense
of what you look like --
tell somebody else
they look like you
and then see how they
immediately respond.
[ Laughter ]
You walk up to a stranger,
"You look like me!"
They're like, "Screw you!"
I'm like, "Damn it, I knew it."
[ Laughter ]
I'm very self-conscious
about my looks.
I got body-shamed
when I was younger.
That's a new term --
body-shaming.
When I was young,
we called it telling a person
what they looked
like to their face.
That was --
[ Laughter ]
I got -- Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, give it up for the '90s!
[ Laughter ]
It was great.
I got made fun of
for having a big forehead.
This girl came up to me,
she said, "You have
a five-head."
[ Laughter ]
At the time,
I'd never heard that term.
I was like,
"What's a five-head?"
And she was like,
"Like a forehead, but bigger --
a five-head."
It sucks when you get made fun
of and then the person explains
how they made fun of you,
and it's pretty good.
You're like,
"That's not bad, actually.
That's clever."
It also sucks --
If you get made fun of
for being fat that's horrible,
but at least you can be like,
"You know what,
I'm gonna diet and exercise,
and I'll show you."
But if you're getting made fun
of for having a big forehead,
there's no really no action
for you to take.
[ Laughter ]
You can't be like, "I'll have
the Caesar salad.
I'm watching
my forehead right now."
[ Laughter ]
I was pretty smart -- I just
tried to keep my eyebrows raised
all of the time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I just looked surprised
all through middle school.
I'm like, "That's unbelievable!"
[ Laughter ]
I'm very body-conscious now.
I go to the gym a lot.
It's hard to tell --
I'm wearing long sleeves.
But I am pretty
ripped under here.
[ Laughter ]
My gym's all body-builders.
I don't like the term,
"body-builder."
I feel like it's too exclusive.
Technically, we're all
body-builders, just some of us
are building crappier bodies
than other people.
[ Laughter ]
I like to lift weights.
My favorite part
of lifting weights
is that break in-between sets
where you kind of
check your phone and go home
for a couple of weeks.
That's my --
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm taking a breather right now,
but I was at the gym
the other day --
I saw a guy lifting weights
in a way I've never seen before.
Have you ever seen this?
He had a thing wrapped
around his head,
and then there was a cord
attached to weights
and he was lifting the weights.
[ Laughter ]
And he was screaming.
He was like, "Aah! Aah!"
I was like, I think we have
different fitness goals.
[ Laughter ]
I was on the elliptical and I'm
like, "That guy's a danger
to society. What?"
[ Laughter ]
I think if you get to the
neck portion of your workout,
you can go ahead and clock out
and head home and hug your dad
for the first time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, he was yelling.
I don't really care for the guys
that yell at the gym.
You see them like, "Beh! Wah!"
I'm like, I feel like
you need fiber more than
you need a workout.
[ Laughter ]
You don't need
to yell at the gym.
They're always
over by the freeway.
That's where you see
the yellers -- by the freeway.
You never really see a guy
on the exercise bike
reading "People" magazine
like, "Aah! Aah!"
[ Laughter ]
I don't yell.
The loudest noise I've ever made
at the gym is, "hoo," you know?
[ Laughter ]
One time I yelled, but it was
for help so I feel like
it was a little
more understandable.
[ Laughter ]
It's a true story -- I dropped
some weight on my chest.
I didn't see the one in front
of the 30, so I kind of
dropped the weight.
[ Laughter ]
Luckily, the neck guy,
he was nearby.
He came over,
he scooped it right off.
He just shot it off.
I was like, "Oh, thank you."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I work out of hotels a lot.
I stay in a lot of hotels.
I was a hotel recently,
I had an awkward moment.
There was a hot tub and
I was sitting in the hot tub,
and I wasn't wearing my glasses
'cause I'd just been swimming.
You can't swim with glasses on.
You'll look like a psychopath.
So...
[ Laughter ]
I was sitting in
the hot tub, no glasses,
and then these two beautiful
women, they came and got into
the hot tub with me
and without thinking,
I got out of the hot tub,
put my glasses on,
and then came back
into the hot tub.
[ Laughter ]
That's really one of
the creepiest things you can do
within the law,
because there's no reason
to go get your glasses that
moment, other than to look at
these women, obviously.
I tried to pretend
I was reading the rules.
I was like, "I wanna see
if we can horseplay.
I thought it might be fun
if we all horseplayed."
[ Laughter ]
And then, my glasses started to
fog up, which is even creepier
when you're like --
[ imitates glass squeaking ]
[ Laughs nervously ]
You guys are great.
Thank you very much.
My name's Joe List.
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking
about there!
That's how to do it, pal!
Look, a standing ovation!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Joe List, everybody!
You can follow Joe on Twitter
@JoeListComedy.